[Music]
in take a news submitted by yeehaw
[Laughter]
taking a knee during the national anthem
has sparked a debate over patriotism
oh my whiz that's when we don't have
[ __ ] to talk about that's it this is a
good country where you live it man I'm
so fortunate wait are they bringing back
the whole Kaepernick thing like when he
yeah it's still about yeah he's still
taking me so I mean you don't have a job
as sure he's not playing no more well I
mean when he did it back then remember
that that was dirty well reason why he
did that so he first did his protest
thing last year yeah and he sat down
during the national anthem and this is
really said then quote I am NOT going to
stand up to show pride in a flag for a
country that oppresses black people and
people of color to me this is bigger
than football and it would be selfish on
my part to look the other way there are
bodies in the street and people getting
paid leave and getting away with murder
so that's what he said then and then he
transitioned to taking a knee to show
respect for military veterans so then
this whole taking anything started
becoming way more popular now because
Trump tweeted so it's changed not for
veterans is it a race thing or is it for
veteran so I started with the whole
racing quote it still is pretty much but
then now everyone is is doing it in
defiance to Trump because of what he
said like his comments towards the NFL
but it's still about that it's still
about so more people are taking a mean
now because of Trump's comment exactly
okay because I don't know where it
started yeah yeah well it started with
the whole like police brutality thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then now Trump's
team is trying to rebrand the whole
protest and to say that everyone that's
protesting is against America it's
against the American flag instead of
what it was in the beginning which was
police brutality so Trump tweeted this
out how is our president
so much time to [ __ ] tweet it makes
me nervous
he said NFL attendance and ratings are
way down boring games yes but many stay
away because they love our country
league should back us so this was after
he made some comments in Alabama saying
wouldn't you love to see one of these
NFL owners when somebody disrespects our
flag to say get that son of a [ __ ] off
the field right now he's fired he's
fired so that's what he said in Alabama
and then he tweeted about NFL and then
that's when everything just how does
this fool have like like the balls to
talk so much [ __ ] about being a patriot
and all this stuff when his wife is like
not even from the US I mean like she has
a [ __ ] craziest accent like she's not
even American herself it's like why why
go against it so much I don't know he's
all kinds of ridiculous
so like even Colin the whole knee thing
it wasn't his idea
he spoke with veterans and they said it
was sitting better with us if you took a
knee instead of just sitting so he got
the idea from veterans but then certain
people started taking it as you're
disrespecting our country you're
disrespecting our flag and that became
the argument instead of what it was
actually about and what a lot of people
didn't know I didn't know until here
recently players weren't even on the
field during the national anthem until
2009 it became a rule because they were
trying to get more people to get into
the military so now everybody's like oh
you're disrespecting our flag like
that's been the thing but it's some new
[ __ ] forever it you know things like
this just started so a lot of people
jumping on bandwagons then and they
don't even know what they're jumping for
yeah the whole NFL doing it after Trump
made his comments was wack to me too
today you're not doing it for the right
reason you're doing it because he called
you a son of a [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty much yeah I don't
understand people tie all kinds of stuff
together like even starting with Colin
like it's just the anthem and you're
taking it as if this isn't the America
it's supposed to be but the person that
wrote the anthem
wrote it in the context of that America
so if that is our anthem then I think
all of us should if you're American you
should pay respect to the anthem that
was written at that time and you can
still stand for the anthem and then just
post on your own social media that you
don't like the climate of today with the
whole police brutality thing and I think
you can do both but I feel like people
are just drawing too many connections
together and just become like this big
old messy thing that doesn't have to be
that way but that's the whole point of a
protest is to it is to make people yeah
feel a little uncomfortable it's to make
people talk about it because issues
aren't being dealt with it's to me you
know it's like shed light on yeah
protests aren't supposed to be like
acceptable that's what a protest is but
the platform is yeah it's like going to
like a Tyler Perry movie and go we need
to stop putting GMO into our food and
everyone at the movie theater is like
what well this platforms not weird yeah
no it's not it's not we're calling like
what the like the star-spangled banner
like what does that have to do with
police brutality its police brutality
and it's about race so when you think
about it well first the song was written
by slave owner it was written while
slavery was in session yeah and the end
of the song is land of the free yeah so
he doesn't believe in the lyrics yeah I
see it's like you can't all of these
things the Constitution all men are
created equal the flip Pledge of
Allegiance all that stuff was written
while slavery was a rant yeah so it's
basically saying we believe all men are
created equal y'all are men though your
savages your beats you gnomes and so as
a black person a person of color anybody
why do we have to respect that that
wasn't written for us true I did so
that's kind of what it is on that sense
here that makes sense
here's photo I think yeah I could I
could see it it's like they're
protesting against the hypocrisy yeah so
yes there's progress and things you know
are better from
our parents generation our grandparents
generation it is better but at the same
time it's not ideal yet it's always fun
right yeah so it's not what they're
saying in these songs and [ __ ] but it
doesn't mean I hate America like they're
twisting the words like just because you
protest doesn't automatically make you
some [ __ ] anti-american communist
it's just saying like I love this
country but I'm gonna exercise my right
to change that because there's something
wrong yeah cuz this is this is this is
what it's about you know I think this is
it's like when employees
Boyka I mean constrict yeah it going
straight they're not quitting they're
saying hey man treat that's better
do you know man yeah treat us better so
we can do this job yeah but I think the
administration is just really saying
like that's that's crossing the line
like when you when you kneel during the
star-spangled banner you [ __ ] well I
think it's just interesting that they're
getting so riled up when it's just like
NFL players like you know what I mean
like it's really that platform like that
like but yeah they're they have
influence but like shouldn't you guys be
worried about like you [ __ ] saying
like we might go to war with [ __ ]
North Korea like I think that's the [ __ ]
they should be talking about not NFL
players you know what's funny I think he
tweeted about like the same bolt or
something yeah and he was like well he
stood for the national anthem he's like
oh they responded back like don't bring
me in your racist [ __ ] like I don't care
you know
funniest thing of this entire like
ordeal that Trump is trying to like
rebrand it as it's disrespecting our
flag so this one Twitter user he tweeted
out this thread it was pretty funny so
he says since disrespecting the flag is
still the narrative being used this
courtesy of the US flag code chapter 10
respect for flag a threaten and so he's
just pointing out like in the actual US
flag code it says right there the flag
should never be carried flat or
horizontally but always aloft and free
they do that [ __ ] in another fell games
like every game like we always you know
lay the the
the flag flat why were the military
carries it and they lay it like on the
field it's above their heads but it's
flat all it's horizontal it's not
supposed to be it should have an example
here because when it's folded it's
different - it's a triangle oh yeah
that's not supposed actual disrespectful
thing it is that is actually yes
but we do it and not standing doing the
national anthem is not listed exactly
those kneeling is still a sign of
respect here and the guys still have
their hands over their heart while their
knee mewling yeah so another another
thing from the flag code says the flag
should never be used as wearing apparel
bedding or drapery shall we all do we
have those are my favorite things to
wear oh yeah you're like oh yeah it's
[ __ ] the American flag looks dope
I want American flag karate gear this
other one that we always do is the flag
should never be used for advertising
purposes and in any manner whatsoever oh
that's like poor sales up with that one
this other one we do all the time is it
should not be embroidered on such
articles as cushions or handkerchiefs
and the like or like or anything that's
disposable like paper napkins oh we got
paper plates we were not like fourth of
July we go ham yeah that's not
everything exactly so these are all
things that like it's listed in the flag
code that that that is disrespectful
nothing in the code says anything about
kneeling standing sitting or any of that
people just want to pick and choose at
handy's I think oh when you burn a flag
- that's that's respectful oh it is it
is so I read the code I thought you
could go to jail for that no so they're
saying that when the flag is it's like
already served its purpose and it's
already like it's weathered and it just
can't be you can't use it for its
purpose anymore you can't throw it away
you have to breath you have like it's a
sign of respect to burn the flag when
it's like you're done using it well
that's a brand-new one I don't know I
think that I guess that would be like it
hasn't even been ironed yet it's just
all it's got the square yes
that's pretty ironic and then the whole
you know fact that Trump is trying to go
out and say like you know this is
anti-american I don't know there's a lot
of similarities but isn't that for
creating more enemies for himself
because I feel like if you're a football
team owner you're probably a Republican
and a trump supporter and then now he's
like kind of alienating all of those
guys you know I mean a bunch of [ __ ]
goes on behind closed doors but Trump as
big of an idiot as he is he's it smart
he knows who to appeal to I wouldn't
even be surprised if he gives no [ __ ]
he really isn't that much of an idiot
yeah but he'd know he knows who to
appeal to he says things like this his
supporters get in rage they get mad but
they feel like seed this is why he's our
guy what are your thoughts on the fact
that a lot of people point similarities
between him and other dictators the way
they became dictators was to create
division in the country and to feel this
like cycle maybe that's his plan to
become a dictator yeah so he may be he
is a judge oh you got competition dude I
know you were saying I forget his tactic
though is all economic like dictators in
the past they want power they want all
this stuff he doesn't care I don't think
Trump really cares about power he
doesn't care about controlling people I
think what he really cares about is
popularity and money so for him he's a
tabloid [ __ ] like he'll do everything
in anything to get more and more popular
to always be in the limelight to be
relevant 24/7 well a lot of people are
also saying like he's he's doing a lot
of these scandals he's saying all these
crazy things to distract us from other
[ __ ] he's doing I mean that's every
presidency oh and she lives there never
gonna talk about the real issues you
know but yeah I think people give Trump
way too much credit like he's too used
the he's the Antichrist they said the
same [ __ ] about Bush
and then the yeah like the left said
that about Bush when you know Bush had
his eight years and then when Obama was
there like people were on the right the
extreme right were saying he's not even
American where is his papers Michelle
Obama's is a transvestite there really
you know those kids aren't there they
say crazy [ __ ] you know like I think
that it's just never ending like when
are we gonna get an honest politician I
don't know I mean with Trump's not a
politician that's why he has the worst
yeah that's true
he's like I mean he I don't know about
his policies but it's like I feel like
he does this kind of [ __ ] because he
doesn't know what to do with the real
[ __ ] when they asked him about Puerto
Rico yeah he he has very little he's
like he don't care see their money
they're we're doing a good job yeah he
what'd he say like we got an a-plus in
Florida I was like an egg plus you give
me some braids and and we will then
Puerto Rico but you gotta understand
there's an ocean between the head in
there it's okay he's a comedian
yeah but the most important thing is
they're kneeling like the [ __ ] it's
weird he's a weird guy howdy do folks
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to subscribe to stay up on their
most recent upload and any other cool
content that we put up there and hit the
subscribe button for the last video
click up here
[Music]